I know why you're happy the uh the
election is over and you don't have to
watch the ads anymore I haven't had a
text from Joe Biden in three days I
feel like he's ghosted me
but hey how about the American people
huh
I didn't have faith they proved me wrong
never so I'm glad really at the end of
the day you know what democracy they
they I think they look at it like the
catalytic converter you know the
they're not quite sure what it is but
they know it would be bad if it got
stolen you know
but of course because this is America we
still don't really know who won
I turned on CNN today it was like it's
the name of every show was election
night 2022. it's Friday
it's Friday
election night is still going on yes
Arizona Nevada Arizona Arizona where
your dad retires and your mom dies
uh and Nevada where he finds wife number
two that's
that's what the balance is
also uh Georgia Georgia is going to be a
runoff Herschel Walker is very excited
he's already raised like three and a
half million dollars for the runoff
he said he wants to make sure that he
gets a first term unlike most of his
children
foreign
[Applause]
well and also a big race that people
watched Pennsylvania anybody from
Pennsylvania this was a big one
shameful Applause uh well John fetterman
pulled it out there uh he had his
problems but he
I see this as a victory of substance
over style he was running against Dr Oz
who's a very Dapper medius Savvy heart
surgeon and he lost to a guy who dresses
like the airline lost his luggage
foreign
[Applause]
also a lot of Firsts this time first gen
Z in Congress
25 year old in Congress also the first
Congress person uh who ran because of a
tick tock challenge uh
and the first Victory party in his
parents basement these are first all
right
[Applause]
of course now the big winner on the
Republican side is the Florida governor
DeSantis won by 20 points down there
even one blue Dade County Miami wow one
Latinos well sure when when you give
away free trips to Martha's Vineyard you
know
uh but also I think you know
DeSantis had a motto I think it
resonated with a lot of people and his
motto was where Florida is where woke
goes to die
of course Florida is where everybody
goes to die so I mean
he's the new Golden Boy in the
Republican Party looks like the media
and the Republican Party certainly the
Republican establisher turning on Trump
for DeSantis
they like the scientists now
so Trump finally knows what it feels
like to be traded in for a younger model
all right
and these blade of course you just say
Trump is going on a rant today went
mental about his a screen about blaming
of course everybody else for this he's
blaming Hannity blaming Steve Wynn
blaming the governor of Virginia and
then uh Kanye stuck his head in the door
and went don't forget about the Jews
he Trump even let you know he blamed for
Dr Oz Melania I'm not blame Melania it
wasn't her best decision
foreign
[Applause]
with her wedding ring and said well I've
made words